[Music]
let's go to susan in chantilly lace with
a pretty what's up susan
in virginia hi hey what's going on
well i seriously considered doing this
call entirely in the song lyrics but
then i realized i'm 40 and i'm tired
listen
to my questions listen
i'm in my 40s too no excuses we only do
song lyrics i'm in if you're in let's do
this
well my last blip knock concert was 20
years ago that's half my lifetime ago
your last name
your last what concert not
slipknot
oh yeah it's been a long time for me too
so if we could do
i'm in
ah i can't hang i couldn't hang all
right i'm i'm i'm tired and old too all
right let's
let's just do it
so my seven and a half year old daughter
seems to have a super high level of
self-preservation
and i just kind of wanted to talk
through
where that would have come from or what
we can do to help her and support her
because it doesn't seem like as i look
out on other her peers
that
she's she seems to be a bit more than
them at this age okay what do you mean
by self-preservation
so
she
doesn't like she doesn't really
associate with peers that much she likes
older kids specifically older girls
and
she seems to look down on peers
judgment judgmentally yeah
and so um my husband and i do a lot to
try to not make our kids feel like
they're wrong about like i don't want to
make her think she's like the way she is
is wrong but i just i don't know how
hard to push her or
um what's developmentally appropriate
and just kind of wanted to get your
feedback oh that's fantastic okay
seven-year-old
who's yeah okay
oh i mean there's a lot of fun we could
have with this one um sure
so out of the bag and
i'm gonna throw some things up against
the wall and your job is to tell me when
i'm wrong okay okay and i have no hard
feelings so you can be like nah you're
wrong
but i'm usually not is that fair is that
cool
um
she
which one of you is like that in the
real world you or your husband or both
my brother your brother
is he with is he in the home with y'all
no
okay she sees him maybe three times a
year and that's
um
you know a day at a time or something he
doesn't you're bro she doesn't see that
so that means it's probably you that
she's getting this from
i guess
it's so great okay
so
here's a couple of like big picture
things
okay number one
coming out of covid
where kids got to spend an inordinate
amount of time with their parents
this is not uncommon
okay
kids have especially younger kids have
been introduced to
adult conversations in a way that they
haven't traditionally been exposed
and so i don't know what your work from
home situation has been like i don't
know what the schooling and the masking
and the homeschool i don't know what
y'all's situation is like
but the first thing is to think of
has your daughter been exposed to more
adult conversations
my six-year-old daughter has um
she
she would rather hang out with well it's
not true not totally but
she's being engaged in more adult
conversations or been around more adult
conversations than my son ever was
because he was in school with a bunch of
other
like
knuckleheads
and so that's number one
the second thing is is
um
kids obs kids
you can imagine me you listen to this
show very often
okay you'll get a kick out of this
um i was in a counseling conference once
and they were talking about childhood
development and the ways to interact
with kids and then the presenter some
fancy
phd psychologist turns around and goes
oh yeah we all know this but i'll just
reiterate it
uh kids under the age i think she said
seven or nine
cannot
process sarcasm
they can't process it so they hear the
words as facts
they'll even laugh with you they'll get
your jokes but their body internalizes
it as data
and i raised my hand i was like i need
to stop you right there say what and so
when i were saying things about like my
closest friends in the world like that
guy's an idiot or oh great my friend
todd's coming over
todd is one of my favorite people on the
planet
but i'm just being a goofy
my son was internalizing that as dad
doesn't want this guy to come over
and then dad got to watch me smile and
carry on and hang out with my friend and
it made my son very confused
see what i'm saying so if your
daughter's growing up in a sarcastic
silly fun
like oh my gosh household
there's an elevated understanding of how
the world works
see what i'm getting at
i think so is that possible
are either of those situations possible
we're not uh
super sarcastic but we are silly okay
and she does use sarcasm
so she's definitely she would have
gotten it from us but i don't
i would have to actually think about
that more okay think about that more and
by the way i should have prefaced this
whole thing with this
everything moving forward
please please please
don't hang on to a shred of guilt
okay
all we're doing is learning like new
skills okay
there's no i don't want you to hang up
and be like oh no our daughter's screwed
up because of me not at all not at all
okay your daughter's clearly got two
parents who love her a lot which is
going to get her as far as she needs to
go okay that's that's really important
here's another question do you have
friends
yes do you go hang out with him
sometimes yes
yeah
do what
oh it's a lot of playdates and then i
just
push the kids away so the moms and i can
talk
so you you go
she gets to see you having adult friends
yes and especially this last year before
that no okay
so this is like a new thing let me ask
you another question
ish and you just alluded to it which
makes you want to high five you
is she the center of the universe
meaning
when your husband you get home from work
your husband gets home from work do you
all have adult talk time then you send
her away
yes okay
so sometimes senator of the universe i
am a part of the adult conversations not
a part of the kid conversations okay so
she definitely definitely wants to be
part of our conversation and she tries
really hard okay oh great and that that
means you are fun to be around right
i wouldn't that's not something to like
lose sleep over tell me when she's with
her friends
what what what's the concerning behavior
so
going back a little bit she was a
daycare baby for four years okay
and i
came home with my kids
and we were home for a year before covet
hit so we were kind of
in internal like figuring out how we
wanted to do things as a family and we
didn't do a lot of social things that
year we started getting involved in our
church and then covet hit and then
everything came to a complete stop and
she was four about yep she was four when
i came home and she was in daycare from
six weeks to the day until her fourth
birthday okay
and so for the first like eight months
when i was home she would cry when we
had to leave the house we have to go get
groceries i don't want you know i don't
want to go that kind of thing
um and so we just took it really easy
and relaxed um she didn't want she still
doesn't want to leave the house
sometimes yeah a lot of the time
um then covet so then this last year we
home school we were part of a co-op and
it took her six to seven months
to warm up to anybody in co-op
um she would beg you to leave as soon as
it was over
even though i was trying to talk to
people and
um
model that
no try to make relationships and my son
is the social butterfly
so he wanted to stay but she just begged
me to leave
so um in the last couple months i've
been able to push her more into
play dates and
activities and she just she walks away
from kids we'll go to the playground and
she'll find the next it's too hot it's
do this it's i'm hungry i want to go i
want to go home it doesn't matter what
it is she finds a reason to not
engage even when the kids are super nice
and they ask her what she wants to play
and what does she want to do she'll go
climb a tree by herself yeah i think it
has less 20 minutes it has less to do
with the individuals and my guess is
her body's telling her she's not safe
with other people
and
um
i would probably like
so like the picture you're painting for
me is a very dialed in remarkable mom
and dad
and
also a weird glitch in the matrix which
i when i say glitch in the matrix
there's a combination of
particular bodies body i have a more i'm
more sensitive to things
then my son is more sensitive to things
than my wife is like in our response to
things okay not in a
helping you know people when they're
sick but i have a more sensitive body my
adhd is a response to a more sensitive
body everybody's got different bodies
right that respond to things
and so you take a body that's
highly attuned highly relational highly
smart
and every day for four years she misses
mom mrs mom and then all of a sudden i
get mom all the time
all the time and you can imagine
don't use your thinking brain
but you can imagine a four-year-old body
that's been a little bit high alert
where's mom where's mom where's mama's
mom just suddenly relaxes in a deep way
for the first time in a long time
and then all of a sudden it's we're
gonna disrupt this and it's like there's
a body saying hey so what we're gonna do
is we've got to over time
teach her body that is actually safe
with other people not only is it safe
that's the key to
growth and peace and all that
given
the as attuned as you and your husband
are
i would if this is my kid i would take
my child to a play therapist and have
them do a assessment of my kid because
i'd want to check and see if is she on
the autism spectrum does she have social
anxiety disorder
is there some some play therapy some
ways that we can get
to some of the fears behind the actions
right
and kids speak via play another thing
you may want to try is drawing pictures
with her
uh okay say like hey we're gonna draw
pictures of us playing with our friends
and you draw a picture of you
sitting with some moms or i don't know
if you play volleyball or tennis or
whatever you go do or you you're on the
softball team whatever is going on
and have her draw pictures of her
playing with kids and that often art can
be a way just like play into a
conversation that otherwise if you just
ask a seven-year-old like why don't you
want to play with everybody she's like i
don't know
um but yeah when you're drawing or when
you're coloring it's another avenue and
the pictures will tell you a lot
okay but i i would if that's my kid i
would i would get with a registered play
therapist in my area and they
are magic and they're really frustrating
to watch if you watch them behind the
one-way glass cause you it really looks
like you're just taking your money and
flushing it down the toilet
you're like what is actually happening
right now and it's pretty magical what
what can happen with a good play
therapist
okay i just watch her
stuff things inside stuff things inside
she won't talk she won't say
you know what's bothering her and it's
just it's all internal and she looks at
people on the playground when they're
laughing and screaming like they're
lunatics i mean
it's like that um
if things are if she's in a room and
it's chaos she she can't she can't she
hates it yeah the show she she cleans it
up
she right she'll clean it all up
not the room i mean like noise like
sunday school at church she doesn't like
to go to sunday school because it's just
a bunch of kids
you know yeah going and playing i would
i would go have her just have a workup
done and they'll give a uh
um a perception inventory that will let
her know like bright lights or loud
noises or things like that it may affect
her a little bit differently and again
she again she may be on the autism
spectrum um i don't know how she you
have to sit down and do an aba
assessment which i'm not qualified to do
but
all to say is it
often
the sounds the noises the experiences
the overwhelming stimulation in an
environment
you just slowly over time teach a kid
how to
a regulate their own bodies and b know
when to step out and see
um know how to interact in there because
we gotta we gotta get on with our lives
the one thing i would caution you on is
um
balancing her need for relationships
which is important with overwhelming
um situations
so if she is tell if her body is telling
you i can't do sunday school it's a lot
right now until you get some more firm
answers i would say cool you can come
sit with me we are going to church
we are leaving the house
but you can stay with me and staying
with me involves not talking
draw you can color on this picture
i will not have a conversation with you
this is not play time mom is engaged in
sunday school mom is engaged in her book
club
but you can sit right there you're not
going to sit on an ipad either i'm not
going to further overstimulate you but
you can um not be in this chaos does
that make sense
yeah oh yeah yeah that's exactly what i
what i wanted to know yeah yeah it is
how hard to to
she she begs me for things to do she
wants friends i know she wants friends
and then it always turns into like i
know she's lonely yeah and that's that's
that that's that that's the scary thing
with not scary that's a dramatic word
that's a heartbreaking thing because she
knows what she's missing
but her body's telling her don't go in
there
yeah and i just feel like i
i just i don't want her to be somebody
other than she is but i'm just i'm
scared that she's going to miss out on
the beauty and magic of
childhood and right fun and tag and
friendships and just because she's so
inside okay two two important things one
yes if she's got
just um a social anxiety what they'll do
is they'll slowly it's exposure therapy
they will slowly turn the dial very
they'll read books about kids playing
with friends they'll draw pictures of it
and they'll talk about it they'll
encourage you to have one friend invite
one friend over to her to your house and
let her play there right so we're gonna
slowly open up the gate there right um
the second thing is this and this is the
pot talking to the kettle okay this is
just two parents
hanging out
i really struggled for the first several
years of my son's life because he's
different than me
and i had a picture of what a great life
was
and it was running around the
neighborhood with a whole bunch of kids
causing chaos and mayhem and staying up
too late and getting in trouble and
that is not my son
and i really wrestled with yeah but if
you would just do these things and he
would put his hands over here you know
what i'm saying like this is
what yeah and so
um i would also challenge you like let
her have her own planet right let it
it's gonna look different she may be a
person who just keys in on one or two
close friends and you're a social
butterfly you like having people
everywhere
so that's letting our kids be them
themselves and letting them be all in on
themselves
it's when they can't they really want to
have friends but
they can't even hang out with one right
they came and hang out with one
all that to say is i mean a lot of these
conversations i have with moms and dads
it's
moms and dads are chaotic and they are
not plugged into their kids and they're
blaming all their issues other kids i
don't see that here at all
not even a little bit i think your
daughter won the lottery with you and
your husband
um
in a pretty remarkable way
um i think now it's a matter of let's
get some professional opinions who can
actually watch her over a couple of
sessions and
see some behavioral patterns
and also um
just take into consideration hey we're
gonna have a friend over to our house
and we're gonna play from this time to
this time and then you can have some
quiet time on the back end i'm not gonna
force your body into things when it's
telling you um otherwise
um but we are gonna have some boundaries
and um you're not gonna run our
household right so this is that that
fine balance there but
hey let me know what the um child
psychologist says the child counselor
says i'd love to
get some feedback on that that would be
really helpful for me just personally
and i want to hear about how your
journey's going